hi
i'm threshing wheat and this last couple
weeks i've been harvesting
and threshing wheat grinding it into
flour and uh
i've finally gotten a system that i
think is working pretty efficiently
so i'll share that with you later in the
video but this whole episode is going to
be devoted to the wheat harvest
which takes up a significant amount of
time but it also nets us a large amount
of calories
and this wheat would have been planted
last fall
when fossil fuels were widely available
and then as fast fossil fuels crashed
through the
spring the wheat grew up and just sat
there and was not able to be harvested
so i had to come
and harvest it by hand using using uh
very minimal fossil fuels i did use my
truck
to move all of the the stuff back to my
house but it was only a mile so
you know we used a minimal amount of gas
really to get this job done
and now i'm in the process of threshing
this is about half of what
i harvested so i'm about halfway through
the threshing
i'll take you through it as i go
but uh welcome to this week in food
magedon
where we're harvesting wheat
hi you usually don't see me here until
the end of the video
but i thought i'd jump on just in case
there's some new viewers to the
foodmageddon
series because of this wheat video and i
just want to let you know what we're
doing
basically um we are simulating the
collapse of fossil fuels
in uh today's food system so back in
january
we started weaning ourselves off of
fossil fuels as if there was some sort
of fossil fuel crisis
luckily this worked out really well
because we were really prepared for
covid hitting
and essentially by september we will be
completely cut off from the outside
world
and the only food that we can add to our
pantry will be
from what we are able to get ourselves
with human power
around our house so part of that process
is harvesting uh the wheat from a nearby
farm and you may see me talk about how
if fossil fuels disappeared
um this is what we would have to do in
actual terms as if it was actually
happening
because what this series is meant to be
is a window into an alternative reality
where fossil fuels have collapsed
so i'll make some links here you can go
back to the beginning and start watching
uh from the beginning if you're
interested we have week
we have episodes almost every week um
telling about how we prepared
what we're doing and how we're coping uh
with the loss of fossil fuels in our
food system
which i think is a really important
thing to consider um especially with the
disruptions in
the food system we've seen since the
coronavirus has been
has been happening so uh yeah have a
look back and i hope you'll subscribe
and share this with some friends so
thanks for watching
it's time to harvest wheat this was
planted last
fall on my neighbor's property but now
you didn't have fossil fuels how would
you harvest it
and luckily i happen to have the tools
to do it
so we're going to be harvesting about a
tenth of an
acre and i'm going to be letting you
know exactly how much work it is to
harvest a tenth of an acre a tenth of an
acre
is about three hundred and 4350 square
feet
and it should have enough uh about eight
bushels
uh worth of wheat which will be
450 pounds of grain
we'll see how it goes well i've done
half a row out of six and i already have
a big appreciation for
uh not only the people that could do
this well hundreds of years ago but also
the modern
machines that you know could do this
with fossil fuels uh
because it's a lot of work and also a
lot of skill
so uh don't take this
as a good instruction this is just me
practicing and learning how to do it
maybe by the by the end of this week
i'll have a good
good rhythm and pattern down but my goal
basically is to use this scythe
to cut and cradle as much weed as i can
and drop it neatly into a pile with all
the heads on one side
and all the stubby tails on the other
doesn't always work out
[Music]
it's quicker i'm finding if i make a
foul
a foul throw to just come and fix it
and i'm getting a lot of shatter which
means a lot of
grain is falling out on the ground
because the heads are shaking and it's
knocking the grain loose
problem is this grain's too dry
i should have harvard this week ago
i don't have that background knowledge
that someone 100 years ago would have
had
to know that i should have done it
earlier
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
now believe it or not doing all this
maybe five minutes with the side that's
the easy part
now i have to bundle them into sheaths
and this is dwarf wheat you can see how
short it is
thanks to norman borlaug and the 1960s
who developed this dwarf wheat
we can grow a lot more wheat on the head
of each
stock than we used to be able to if this
wheat were as tall
as old wheat was then it would lodge the
head would be too heavy for the strand
and it would knuckle it would lodge in
the ground and become useless
so they shortened the wheat it was a
japanese dwarf variety they broke cross
spread it
shortened the wheat and now you can grow
tons of wheat on each stock
however i can't do what i used to do
which was use the stock itself
as a binder for a sheep of wheat or a
clump a group of wheat that you'd
bind together you just use the wheat
itself to do it this is too short so i
have to use twine which is kind of
annoying
but now i have to bind all this together
now in
days long ago when people actually mowed
their own wheat like this
this would be the job of two binders for
every one
mower because you can mow twice as fast
as you can bind
so usually it would be the husband
generally doing the siding
the more evenly you mow this the easier
it is for the binders
so you had to be as skillful as possible
not to upset
the people that had to come after you
and and clean it all up
and then the wife and older older kids
helping with the binding and the younger
kids
they'd be picking up off the ground
these loose heads
and stuffing them in a sack these are
gleanings you may have heard in the
bible
or maybe old accounts of agriculture
gleanings in fields this is what you
pick up off the ground that's not
attached to the stock anymore
and biblically you're supposed to leave
it for poor people and the birds
i may or may not do that i might just
pick it up myself
so we'll see we'll maybe get some kids
out here soon to help me
help me with this so after about eight
hours of harvesting total i have all
these sheaves of wheat
which are bundles of wheat piled in my
garage
and i have to process them into grain as
quickly or process them to get the grain
out as quickly as possible
each one of these heads has
grains and chaff in them and so i have
to
essentially do that to all
every single head to get the grain out
and the process to get that grain out is
called threshing and there's
many different ways to do it the
traditional way would be to put this all
on a
on the ground and beat it with flails
um or have oxen
trod over them until they knock all the
heads loose or have kids jump on it or
beat it with sticks there's all kinds of
different ways to do it depending on
where you are in the world
another kind of low budget way to do it
if you have
a small plot of of wheat that you want
to work
is to use just a clean tub
so this is a clean garbage bin i have
never used it for garbage it's only for
food and food related processing
so if i take this sheath open it up and
this is why it's important to get all
the heads
on one side of the sheath and all the
the straw on the other side so you don't
have to
go through later and pick through and
make sure that it's aligned see here i
have to turn
grab all these heads and turn them
around
so that they're all aligned to one end
and this increase
this is what really increases the time
to process
so it really behooves you
to make sure you align all the grain
really carefully in the field
to save yourself time later and then
really i just take
these heads of grain and beat them
beat them on both sides and you can see
the grain heads are still here but
there's no grain left in
them all of the very dry seeds
have dropped out so now that's just
straw straw
straw is when it doesn't have any seeds
in it hay is when it does
so now it's straw this is hay and this
is straw technically speaking
so we could do that a lot but um
i've built a flailing
uh a flailing machine basically
that can be run by bicycle i'm gonna use
a motor
an electric motor because it's just me
you need two people to operate if you
run it with a bicycle
but it's right behind me here so let's
have a look at that so over here i have
essentially what amounts to
a large octagonal drum
and right now i have it set it this can
close but right now i have stops in here
and i'll show you why later
so what you can do is put in your wheat
here close it latch it and then ride a
bicycle
and it turns a series of flails and shut
inside and i'll show you that in a
minute
i have it set up right now with this
opening so that i can
let it run and i will stick the sheaves
of wheat in as you'll see but this is a
little bit of a modification to run as a
one person operation as opposed to a
a two-person operation you could run it
as a batch meaning you put it in
run it for a set amount of time and then
clean it out
i'm gonna run it continuously and just
keep putting heads in until it's full
um so what this is essentially is a
central axel
with these flails that uh spin in kind
of a worm pattern
so it pushes everything this way
and then this the seeds and chaff
fall down uh this
this open slot in the in the on the side
so i add
things over here and it gets beaten as
they move down
and then i have to clear out all the
straw and the excess chaff
but most of this or almost all the seeds
and some of the chaff falls down through
this gap and uh you're not supposed to
run it with it open
but we'll do it here just for fun so you
can see
now this gets to be very dusty so i'm
going to wear a respirator
and i'm going to tie my hair up with a
bandana to keep the dust out of my hair
that here comes the respirator which
makes it a little hard to talk plus
it'll be loud anyway
but essentially what i'm going to do is
take from my
wheat over here and then as this is
spinning put the heads of grain in
and those flails will knock the wheat
right off of it
then i can pull the straw out and put it
in that
waiting wheelbarrow so
here we go
[Music]
okay so oh sorry get my respirator off
okay so now that i've run it
in here we've got
a chopped
and straw stuff on top i can just take
out because all the grain
is falling to the bottom so i can pretty
safely just
grab this stuff and chuck it out
what's left in here is just grain and
chap
[Applause]
and i'll just sweep all that grain
down a little gap there
take the straw out
there we go ready for the next batch
underneath then
is the bucket now this is full
of chaff and seeds so i'm going to run
it through a sorter
and then we'll do some winnowing and
we'll do some winnowing to get to the
grain
and now we have the sorting machine
which is a series
of boxes basically with different sizes
of screening them from
quarter inch to eighth inch
to window screen below and each one is
going to separate
out different sizes of seeds or chaff
and what i want
is to save everything that comes out of
this gap so at the bottom of this chute
i have a bucket that will catch
hopefully
most of the grain that's going to come
through so let's have
a look to see here
and now i can use
on the side here i've got a handle
now so my angle isn't very steep so i
get a lot
that gets stuck up here and a lot of
this is chaff but we'll get rid of that
on the next go through
all right now i have my bucket of mostly
similar sized chaff and then underneath
are a whole bunch of seeds that are kind
of hard to see
okay and now i have a widowing tower so
essentially what this is
so a fan sucking in air
it blows it up this tower and then back
out so there's
good wind coming out right here now what
happens
is i pour the chaff and the wheat
into this hopper and it has a little
door a choke
door that i can adjust here so it'll
just let out a trickle
of the chaff and the wheat and the seeds
will drop down in here
and as they drop the wind will blow the
chaff
up and out and down here the heavier
wheat seeds will fall
and drop there's a screen here that
catches them
and then drops them into this bucket
this is
a more a fancier way to do it than you
could i could just
sit with a bucket underneath the fan and
then
pour the other bucket but that needs a
lot more attention and time
this only should take one or two passes
and the grain should be cleaned
at this point it's pretty clean that's
some here
i can just kind of
i finally gotten a system that i think
is working pretty efficiently
so i'll share that with you so the first
step i take
is i use my trusty uh threshing tub here
[Applause]
and i grab a sheaf of wheat
and you know i've done this different
ways in
other parts of the videos you'll see
where i can feed this directly into my
thresher
but i'm finding this to be a more
efficient use of my time so what i do is
i hold it over
my bucket by straddling it
and then i just cut the heads off
now if this wheat has been bundled
really nicely and all the heads are on
one side
i can get by with just cutting the top
half or so of the
the sheath into this bucket but
in many cases i end up having to
cut this wheat into quarters and just
throw it all in because the heads get
dispersed throughout the entire
length of the sheath in future years
i might uh make more
effort to make sure that everything is
aligned in the field
because that would mean i have to thresh
half the amount
of wheat or half the amount of straw so
i still have a lot of heads in here
sometimes if there's only a few i'll
pick them out so now
i take this bucket full of
cut up straw and drop it into my
thresher
and i can do about half a sheaf at a
time
otherwise it gets overloaded and it
won't thresh properly there's not enough
space in there
close that up turn on two
switches i turn on the fan which i'll
show you in a minute
the fan blows the chaff away as it falls
out from underneath saving me the
windowing step
that you've seen elsewhere in the video
and then i turn on the motor
30 seconds seems to be about plenty
then i can check look through and find
some heads
and give him a feel if i
try three of them and they're all
threshed then i consider it to be
done yep all the heads are off
so now this just goes in my
wheelbarrow
[Music]
and the process continues i'll add more
to the progression machine and start it
back up
so what happens here is wheat and chaff
fall out of this this vent here in the
bottom of the thresher
they hit here and the chaff is blown
away
by this fan which i have on running on
the high speed
this is a trash can lid this is my food
trash can that never actually uses
gets trash on it it's just a big
container of food safe plastic that i
keep clean
um and this ends up obviating
both the sorting that you saw as well as
the winnowing for the most part i'll
have to winnow it a couple times
but i don't need to use my big winnowing
tower i have all this extra equipment
that i don't actually need to use now
so that's fun so here let me uh turn
this on and we can see it in action
and there's a little bit to toss out but
for the most part
this does a pretty good job with about
80 to 90 percent
of the chaff i usually have to deal with
so
makes pretty clean and pretty quick work
of the the rest of the winnowing process
i take the half windowed
bucket our lid and pour it into a bucket
and then later i'll winnow this for the
remaining
small amount of of chaff that remains in
here
not fully clean but pretty close just a
couple of rounds of winnowing will get
that ready to use
and now i'm in the garage i'm building a
stand that's going to go behind my
stationary bike
to grind wheat and other things into
flour
or other ground seeds
[Music]
so
okay now what i have is my finished
stand with my grain mill mounted here
and my wheel v-belt that turns down
there
so what i need to do now is connect the
belt
so this is a variable length belt
because this is kind of a long
connection it's about seven
feet of belt that i need
and most belts aren't seven feet long
plus i'd have to cut a hole in this to
make
to get it through so this variable
length belt just seemed to be like
the best solution to all of my all of
life's problems
other than the fact they are kind of
annoying to get set up but once they're
set up they're great
they have less vibration supposedly
than a regular belt and again this is
not a how-to blog so i'm not going to go
through
the exact way to deal with these belts
because there are people with more
expertise on them than me
but suffice it to say it's a whole bunch
of links of a polymer
a polymer plasticine type thing
and they link together in a pretty
clever way
got two there links through it's got
little notches
and they're pretty cool uh so look up a
variable
or a link to b v belt on youtube and you
can find all kinds of videos about how
they work
and what they're about um
i'll link to one here if i get around to
it
all right the nice thing is i can put it
right through a hole without cutting
a slot right because i have it in a in a
closed hole in the wood
the fewer openings i have the less place
for
flour and other bits to get everywhere
because
everything that gets covered in flour
will attract rodents and then once you
get rodents you get feces and urine
and then it makes it unsterile and unfit
to use
so i really do want to keep this stuff
as
cleanable as possible and having a more
enclosed house
housing is one way to do that
there we go let's see
hey it's turned the right way and
everything
now we have to limit this to 300 rpms
so now i need to count how many
rpms this takes for every spin of this
cool it's only five that's awesome that
means i can turn
at a much more comfortable pace
oh yeah that's much better than using my
arm
and now i take that cleaned grain that i
just cleaned
all these bits of of wheat
and i'm going to put them on top of this
hopper and fit these
stainless steel burrs on my mill
i've kind of jerry-rigged
a little hopper with a spout
here it could be a little more permanent
once i get it exactly how i want it but
for now
i'm going to do it with this
and again this can be run by a bicycle
and
all winter i anticipate i will be
running it with a bicycle so i can
have some exercise when i'm stuck inside
on the snowy snowy days
but for today i'm going to run it on an
electric motor
powered by our solar panels and battery
so now i will fill this hopper
with about three quarts of grain
now usually i'm only going to grind this
right before i use it so i'm about to
use this flower
otherwise i just keep it in the berry
form in these buckets in my basement
but since i'm going to use this flour
i'm going to grind it now
[Music]
okay now it's time to use the flower and
so this is
some of the flower eye ground and this
is not whole wheat flour this is whole
grain flour
and i'm finding that it is much more
difficult to bake with
than white flour that you buy at the
grocery store the main reason is
when you're baking with white flour and
you need it right we all
most of us know that uh kneading it
forms the gluten which are
chains kind of think of them as like
elastic bands that form
in the structure and that's what gives
it that that bready
consistency that we like the bran
and the the germ and the other things
that are left in the flower
act like little glass shards so imagine
you have
a bowl full of rubber bands that you
want to make the gluten right and then
you throw a bunch of glass in there and
you need it
it cuts all those bands to bits and so
you don't have that nice gluten
structure that you generally would want
so i've had to adapt and i still don't
have a good handle on baking with this
yet so i'm still learning
one tip that i did learn is that when
you
mix it instead of putting your water and
your flour together and mixing right
away
you want to let it sit for about 10
minutes and that weakens and breaks up
the brand and the other bits that would
otherwise break the gluten down it it
causes them to soften
and breaks less of your gluten so that's
one tip i've learned
from the internet but i still have a lot
of adjustments to make in my usual bread
making process
so i'm just gonna make a simple
sourdough
and here i have my sourdough starter
that i mixed last night it's active
so i'll take my mixing bowl
my scale and now i'll add a pound and a
half of the whole grain flour
and then i'm gonna add a half a pound of
white flour
just to give me a little extra wiggle
room and then i'm going to add
four ounces of this starter into a well
in the middle and then a tablespoon of
salt
and since this is a two pound loaf i'm
going to do
about 70 percent hydration so i will add
a pound of water it's 50
and then another five ounces
of water and then i'll mix that up real
lightly just so kind of mixed in and
then i'll let it sit
for 10 minutes before kneading
[Music]
all right it's been 10 minutes
and instead of just letting this mixer
run or kneading it
continuously i'm just going to knead it
for a minute and let it rest for a
minute knead it for a minute let it rest
for a minute that if
in effect has the same effect as needing
it for 10 minutes if i do
that on off on off for 10 minutes it's
going to be the same effect
now instead of using my usual kneading
method it's risen some i'm going to
just stretch and pull the dough
trying to build up the gluten and the
structure
if i need it i'm afraid i'm going to
overwork the dough really easily just
because of the
the different nature of this so just
draw
and pull over
i'll let that do a little more rising
now
[Music]
and now i'm oiling up a pan
and drop the dough into it now that it's
risen again
never mind the noise of the fire truck
being pushed around
the floor over there
so the goal is to give this a little bit
of a structure so i'm using the pan
i haven't gotten to the point where i
have enough control over this dough
to make a freestanding loaf
but hopefully
the pan will give this enough
form that it will keep all of its
nice bubbles inside
[Music]
let's see if i can if i can shape this
thing it's pretty wet
and i don't want to overwork it because
we'll just tear all the gluten
[Music]
that is one wet loaf
i guess i could challenge reduce the
challenge on myself by making a drier
loaf but
all right let's get a
flower covered tea towel over that to
rise
they also say that it's possible
to sieve out
white flour from this and you lose about
a third of the content
so i haven't tried this before but let's
see yeah
yep that would do it so here's all that
bran and germ
and other things left over from the
grinding process
so i can make brand muffins and other
hearty things by adding that back in
and then here's the white flour oh yeah
definitely
so maybe i will
try baking with the white flour someday
but for now
[Music]
let's mix it all back in
okay it's as risen as it's gonna get
425 and fingers crossed
well definitely not my greatest loaf of
bread
needs workshopping to work with this new
flower
is it getting better are you learning oh
yeah for sure
yeah uh it's just that
so used to cooking with baking with
regular flour i did i did try and sift
some of that some of it out and i
totally can do that so
i just did have you tried doing the
overnight
same same thing yeah
it's all that sharp you know the bran
and the stuff and the gluten
you know what i should do is try and do
justice i'll sift an entire loaf
and do just white bread from the stuff
that i've harvested just to see how that
goes
and then i'll have all that bran we can
do things with like i don't know
brand muffins which are yummy oh
melted over the sides and now it's stuck
in here
yeah this one took a beating oh
i mean the bread the the crumb itself
looks fine but the top
well that was not my finest baking hour
i used to work in a bakery i can
actually bake bread
um and i have other videos that i'll
link to here and here about
making sourdough starter and also uh
baking
baking bread so have a look at those for
a little more successful
yeah a little more successful baking
yeah well that's all we have this week
thanks for joining us for this episode
of foodmageddon i hope
uh you learned a little bit about what
it takes to process wheat into flour and
the amount of work
we take for granted when we buy a
10-pound bag of flour at the grocery
store
um wheat's been a
this has been a goal for me for for
years to do this um so i've been really
excited
uh and enjoying it for the most part but
i imagine that if i had to do this every
year
uh it would be it would become
quite the chore um anyway uh
thanks for watching again uh don't
forget to subscribe uh share this with
your friends uh post us on uh social
media you can find us on social media
we're at
low tech institute on facebook
instagram uh on twitter we're low
underscore techno
uh you can find our podcast the low tech
podcast on
apple itunes google play stitcher and
others
you can reach me i'm scott at low tech
institute dot org
which is also our website
lowtechinstitute.org where we have a
blog
we have all kinds of different projects
going on we're doing a beep reading
project we have
uh lots of other things right now i'm
writing about
covet 19 in the long view of history on
our blog
i've been doing an essay series where
i'm adapting a book i wrote
why did ancient civilizations fail to
look at our current situation
with the pandemic to kind of put it in
global historic and prehistoric
perspectives so check that out
at lowtechinstitute.org thanks again for
watching
stay tuned for next week we'll be back
to our regular program where we're
working in the garden largely uh
harvesting
uh cucumbers and tomatoes i think next
week so
stay tuned for that thanks for watching
and take care of yourselves
[Music]
so
you